the all-time greatest finishes in nfl
history let's get through as many as we
can we got a few minutes left serene
i'll let you go first although i have a
feeling i know where you're going oh
yeah you know where i'm going mike 1975
the original hail mary and of course it
it did be great and it ripped your heart
out and we got great we got highlights
back
what a great thing of course we did
and go ahead and say the push off go
ahead and say it there it was there it
was all crowd saw it everybody saw it
except the officials shireen
well you'll have a chance to get back
mike because i have a feeling that the
catch may be on your list and that one
as a kid ripped my heart out but this
was of course my favorite play of all
time having grown up a cowboys fan look
at the push what i mean i know nothing
about high level defensive back
technique in mid 1970s but diving
forward when the ball is coming in was
not taught by anyone at any time in the
national football league all the way
back to the beginning of the sport hey
the ball's coming in here's what you do
you dive forward and land on the ground
that's not what nate wright did and oh
yeah since you're gonna go there let's
go ahead and even it out right now the
catch that was the moment and when you
think about
the teams of the 70s that had that
hammer lock on greatness and it was
always the steelers the cowboys the
raiders the dolphins and always one of
them and to have the 49ers who were just
bad throughout the 70s disrupt things
the way they did
the way it happened with the joe montana
roll out because even though the 49ers
earned home field advantage in that game
no one believed in the 49ers and then
came that moment and the the catch in
the end zone and it just that just kind
of popped the bubble on the 70s and we
got into a new age of football where
it really did feel like you know
other teams were gonna have a chance
then that constant lather rinse repeat
steelers cowboys raiders dolphins and uh
even though the you know the patriots
have screwed everything up over the last
20 years it's still far better than it
was back in the 70s when there were four
teams that ruled the sport and the rest
of them were just we're just tackling
dummies
and it kind of signaled the the 49ers
and joe montana were there for a while
right that was kind of the defining
moment for them to go and they they did
it they got it done against the cowboys
mike
all right one more let's see what do you
got
well i voted in that 100th year thing of
the greatest plays of all time so i'll
go with the immaculate reception because
i do think it was the greatest play of
all time with the catch second and it
was just an outstanding play by franco
harris a miracle
then why did you take the 75 playoff
game first why didn't you start with the
immaculate reception why do you think i
did you're just trying to stick it to me
she's sticking it to me of course
immaculate reception
we had the question recently of what you
would have tattooed on you football wise
and i would i would do the immaculate
reception because that was the moment
that i discovered the nfl when the house
was full of grown-ups and they went
crazy and i was playing with my hot
wheels i thought i better start paying
attention to this because this is an
interesting thing and it was all thanks
to franco harrison the immaculate recep
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports